which of the ordered pairs is a solution
of the following equation
4x minus 1 is equal to 3y plus 5.
now when we look at an ordered pair and
we want to figure out what's whether
it's a solution we just have to remind
ourselves that in these ordered pairs
the convention the standard is is that
the first coordinate is the x-coordinate
and the second coordinate is the
y-coordinate so they're gonna if this is
a solution if this ordered pair is a
solution that means that if x is equal
to 3 and y is equal to 2 that that would
satisfy this equation up here so let's
try that out so we have 4 times x well
we're saying x needs to be equal to 3
minus 1 is going to be equal to 3 times
y well if this ordered pair is a
solution then
y is going to be equal to 2. so 3 times
y y is 2
plus 5. notice all i did is wherever i
saw the x i substituted with 3 wherever
i saw the y i substituted it with 2. now
let's see if this is true
4 times 3 is 12 minus 1. is this really
the same thing as 3 times 2 which is 6
plus 5.
see 12 minus 1 is 11 6 plus 5 is also
11. this is true 11 equals 11.
this this pair 3 comma 2 does satisfy
this equation now let's see whether this
one does 2 comma 3. so this is saying
when x is equal to 2 y would be equal to
3 for this equation
let's see if that's true so 4 times x
we're now going to say see if if when x
is 2 y can be 3. so 4 times x
4 x 2 minus 1 is equal to 3 times y now
why we're testing to see if it can be 3
3 times 3 plus 5. let's see if this is
true 4 times 2 is 8 minus 1 is this
equal to
three times
is this equal to three times three
so that's nine plus five
so is seven equal to fourteen no clearly
seven is not equal to fourteen so these
things are not equal these things are
not equal to each other so
this is not a solution when x equals 2 y
cannot be equal
equal to 3 and satisfy this equation
so only 3 comma two
is a solution